hello everybody and welcome back to the
fan scription podcast I am Walter
Venezia I thought you were Zacks matter
well you know what today you back your
right rap we are here today to talk
about Avengers infinity war if you're
watching this podcast or listening to it
you just probably saw the what if Zack
Snyder director dove a directed Avengers
infinity war which just went up so we
mentioned at the end of the last podcast
I was gonna be doing more of a comedic
episode a little bit lighter in tone I
have to admit I was worried you were
worried concerned what were your
concerns Robin I just thought cuz like
we've been doing this taking it
seriously there's like I don't know to
do a jokey episode and like we haven't
been able to see the comments yet but I
when I saw it I'm like okay this is
really freaking funny oh thank you
appreciate yes you're Zack Snyder kills
me all the time it's just part of who I
am now I want to do infinitely more to
the Snyder Inc we did a video called the
style you know you can check out on this
channel right now also the Christmas
Snider ring at sequel which is basically
a Christmas carol feature yeah just full
of snide miss right now I said your your
Snider I'd never realized until I saw
that video it's got a bit of a like Joe
said John Mulaney which I never thought
a little bit a little little sometimes
occasion it's a little spider hammy just
like yeah I can see any float in the air
when you smell a freshly baked pie Zak
that advocate I can see that now yeah I
mean I didn't know John Mulaney was who
he really was until a couple years ago
so I love his stand ups yeah I showed up
a little spider-man I'm like yes right
now he has a very funny like old timey
voice like that so I got yes the kind of
the comparison for sure this is not
gonna be a regular thing maybe once in a
while we'll do something like this but I
really wanted to do something came out
in April - yeah it works with April
April Fool's The Late Late Pro fools he
coined last time we did this podcast so
it's not gonna be regular thing don't
worry next month we'll be back to the
regular fan scription episodes taking it
seriously and having a lot of fun with
it so this is just something little bit
different but I hope you guys enjoyed
but so we're here today to talk not
really too much about Snyder but more
about Avengers infinity war and the
upcoming Avengers endgame which is
coming out in a couple
days and we're just gonna give our
predictions and stuff like that but
let's talk about infinity war first so
when I first saw this movie like
everyone did a year ago I was I was kind
of shocked I guess I would like to look
at I laughed I cried I kissed 12 bucks
goodbye yeah right basically I was but
you know by the ending by the way if
you're watching this spoilers I don't
know just in case everyone dies at the
end of Infinity Ward if you haven't seen
infinity war yet two days before and the
next one's gonna come out I think we're
good yeah right just in case that I
don't know I get a lot of crap for
spoiler stuff sometimes I do my bad well
mask of the phantasm by using a pronoun
give me a break did that really happen
yeah dude horsemen were anyway it's like
you've had 20 years to see it twenty
multiple yeah over that 23 or something
but anyway we're not talking about that
we're talking about infinity war get
back on topical I'm trying so we got
back you know going back to watch this
I've seen it about twice since the
theater it definitely holds up I mean
you know we're gonna see how well it
holds up after endgame comes out because
it's basically the second part of this
whole yes story so it kind of Empire
Strikes Back rising or didn't really end
yeah
but also part of me honestly everyone
was shocked and theater was like a
funeral when you know the credits were
rolling and stuff but part of me kind of
hoped that this was it like I know it
wasn't gonna be it ends with farm like I
was like kinda like okay with it I was a
peaceful I have some very grumpy
mornings I'm just like yeah Fanus was
right my name is 50% of population wiped
out right yeah it not the fact that he
was right or his is like motivations
were altruistic or anything which you
can argue they kind of work but not
really that it's more just you know
we've never seen this kind of thing
before where yeah something so big just
ends like that
you know I get you know I that were in
the ultimate trol moment just the end
and that's just moment but what a great
way to go out though honestly if they
did that like Thanos came week you had
six years waiting for him someone
the Russo brothers would be in witness
protection I'm sure they would but this
is worth it they have Secret Service
around I know it just kind of it just a
small part of me but still it's like
that would have been that would have
been something huh that would have been
something interesting to see like the
reaction to and like no that's it
or maybe you're messed up or maybe if
they would have waited like a couple
years and they like just drop the movie
like oh yeah by the way it's like what I
mean know what I mean
it sails easy now that's there right but
there's no possible way that you know
with promoting and everything then
finding a unicorn is easier than getting
tickets to the stand I know the end game
has got a lot of sold-out places where I
go you most of the time the midnight
screenings or the nine midnight
screenings anymore they're like the
evening before is that Thursday um
they're never sold out so I'm hoping
that doesn't happen when I go cuz I'm
not buying in advance because I never do
but we'll see what happens
did you buy in advance oh yeah yeah no
I'm gonna say is good luck buddy all
right well I'm hopefully gonna get a
review of that up weird we but my wife
and I were basically like buying buying
them in advance and like with the whole
computer like the whole internet
crashing across the world because people
are buying tickets to this damn thing
yeah all these websites like shutting
down there yeah for sure but in terms of
infinity war I mean that's how I felt
about I thought it was really well done
though just in terms of the quality of
moving the storytelling in the
characters I thought everything was done
great and I'm hoping that they follow
through with endgame with the story I
know that they're gonna go probably go
back on some of those things that happen
at the end the movie with killing
everyone off and most of everyone's
gonna be brought back but who's gonna be
killed in this one for good and we'll
talk about who that is in a minute but I
want to get your thoughts just some
Infineon work first I know you had the
original comic book writers I did eons
ago so let know let me get your thoughts
on that seeing maybe most of the changes
like didn't bother me so like the
biggest change that I can remember is
there were a couple couple big changes
one fan OHS does kill a ton of people
including our heroes though they're in
very unique ways which
I alluded to in that scene where the
guardians were going up against him and
like they were like weird things were
happening to them like with him using
the Infinity stones but so I wasn't
expecting quite the wipe out everything
wipe out all our heroes at once well
like it was much more kind of battle
based like whereas this one is just like
just poof like that so that took me a
bit by surprise because I don't remember
quite going down like that in the comet
in the comics I got a lot of flack it
was like people died that comes up like
that wasn't when I met it was like the
way it went down I'm different here sure
and then the other big thing was he was
doing it if I remember for Lady Death
which was a character and honestly I
think it's cool we met Thanos is doing
this for himself and not just to impress
somebody well thanks write it oh he's
even reading it I'm like yeah that was
pretty weird
and then I don't think we're gonna have
was it Adam warlock getting the team
back together I think the exercise that
I feel like they're they're gonna do
with that I don't know I I don't know
what they're doing just cuz I thought
for a second that it looked like the
Hulk maybe was gonna take that role on
if like getting the band back together
but I I don't know what's gonna happen
with that and then like I know they
teased him at the end of guardians to so
he's gonna be in Guardians 3 I'm
assuming but are they gonna like do
another tease he's gonna escape at the
end credits or something are we gonna do
labor the infinity war like knockoffs
like down the road like phase twelve or
fourteen alright man so I don't know but
um so those are the big changes I did I
I did miss a central figure uniting them
that was the only thing that I'm like
okay I did miss then none of the other
changes from what I remember and again
like I hadn't that read this since 1993
hmm yeah it didn't bother me okay
as a movie itself I thought it was
really good um I've never thought any of
these giant ones like I know Ares like
the previous copy that movie ever made
them like it's
fine the first Avengers has not eaten as
well as I think people thought it would
yeah but it still really it's very it's
very fun yeah I like I like guardians of
the galaxy better no I have something to
- I like I like yeah there's a lot of
them that like a lot of the smaller ones
I kind of like better so this is one
where I enjoyed it a lot and it was cool
because like my friends and I were super
into infinity war back when we were
right
basically like 13 you know it was cool
to just like be like wow it's you know
somebody twenty-something years later
and to see this like come to life like
it's it's kind of amazing we never
dreamed as kids that this would happen
because comic book movies just weren't
like that so that was super cool as a
movie itself I'm like yeah that's really
good I drink it up they're like not my
favorite item like I said earlier I
think we're gonna have to wait and see
how the story ends to really judge this
one on its own yeah the one thing that
didn't happen to me is having read the
comic and knowing just where it's going
hmm
in a general way everybody flipping out
about like you know all the characters
they killed out like oh my god I'm just
like you have no idea my guys are coming
back right you know most of all right
yeah I know you're right
I love chadwick boseman response have
you seen him in interviews oh I try to
they try to ask him what's going on like
it so about Black Panther - and they try
to ask them stuff and goes like yeah so
then I don't know I did not give in like
I I feel like a lot of just generally
talking to people I feel like a lot of
the people that like had the full mental
breakdowns at the end and we're like
crying and this and that didn't grow up
with infant anymore as a comic get
something they experienced there so
they're watching this for the first time
like maybe not seeing that coming you
know oh okay like yeah I guess and
that's that that is a huge disadvantage
for some of us that are older who may
have read it already and knew what was
coming like because I'm just like it it
was still great to see well not great to
see it was sad but you know it didn't
have that same impact for me where I'm
like yeah
not like destroyed that was more like
guys calm down
but I thought it was well done like it
was my favorite line in here hey miss
just a boy yeah I just I went very
over-the-top with this one so yeah I I
thought it was a good movie yeah I
enjoyed it a lot I agree I mean in terms
of you know just rewatching and recently
for the transcription episode it's still
I still am very affected by it
I mean it's still just like and you're
you just get hyped up to see the end of
the story with endgame everything so I
thought for me I think I think gamora's
demise was the one that got to me the
most because I was like I I was just
like oh like the that one was like the
others I could see like like that one
I'm like I can't remember like I don't
remember that in the comic like but I
mean again it's been so long so and I'm
sure I'll get correct a thousand times
but yeah that one like kind of took me
what like you could see it coming like
like the second it's like well this is
what you gotta have to do I'm like oh no
like but still I was like oh no it was
rough yeah it was rough with the the
Gomora death for sure and I'm not I just
like her as a character I'm like a chili
the thing that's great about gamora's
characters that she gets better with
each appearance that she makes in the
MCU so she does yeah so my god cuz I
liked her fine and Guardians but it's
just like she just she just gets better
and better absolutely and infinity war
was I mean she had some of the best
scenes that home calls totally stole the
show no in a number of scenes so
definitely and I loved man I you know
sometimes I complain about the the
Guardian stuff were they have a really
great serious dramatic scene happening
and they always have to undercut it with
the joke all the time that's just James
Gunn's writing or direction or whatever
and that's his preference and in this
one they had that great scene with
Gomorrah and star-lord about her asking
him to kill her
mmmph nanos gets her and he finally
agrees to it reluctantly
it's a great scene and then you just
hear Batista Drax in the background he
in the freakin hook the the zorb nuts or
whatever those were so that's that
didn't bother me that I know I actually
liked Marius
my goodness maybe because there's so
many other dramatic points in the movie
where that didn't happen every scene
yeah like something in credit credit to
James gun there's something about
guardians where in some other Marvel
movies it's it's never been a deal
breaker for me and Marvel movies but it
is something I noticed and I yeah
sometimes I'm like okay soon it joke um
yeah there is something about the way
gun does it that it seems so within
their characters that I feel like
everything is out of character but there
are other Marvel films I've seen where
sometimes like we needed a joke here so
bad I'm like I just feel like even in
the serious moment like a character when
if like crack wise about that like
occasionally I'll see one where I'm just
like you didn't need that there sure
with with guardians guards galaxy 2 is
the one where I kind of was like all
right because we get really great
serious stuff with ego and star-lord and
like learning all his bags during all
this stuff and even beyond that with
Drax and mantis and all this stuff
happening and but there's always just
like we rewrite of a yonder
oh yeah dude yeah dude sorry cuz we're
talking about land over here dude sorry
yeah no we were talking about that Star
Force yeah I'm psyched to see land on
him man I am too but ya know it just um
Dorian stew is where I kind of felt that
was it kind of you didn't need all that
stuff to happen every single scene but
in yeah like I said in infinity war I
think that there especially that one
scene I was rolling um yeah guardians is
weird because like I know there's a lot
of people like the second one better I
still think I prefer the felt like the
forever better for sure but I liked the
second one no I'm absolutely not
agreeing so in terms of any other
thoughts just on Infinity Ward with how
do you think famous was handled I mean
great villain I got use to the fact that
he looks like a giant purple version of
the blanking on that show Pawn Stars
the guy from Pawn Stars which one
Chumlee no not Chumlee
to dad haven't you seen that whenever
like washing them together that no no
yeah now I'm not the old man just the
Rick Harrison yeah Rick it looks like
Rick from pot-stirrer there's somebody's
doing a mashup somebody was doing a
great mashup of like the two of them
like giving him like turning him purple
and like hilarious yeah I didn't I
thought he was handled well it's really
one of those things where it's like you
can draw something in a comic and you
don't blink I never even blinked looking
at Thanos in the comics and like you
know I've got a big picture hanging in
my office of something that my friends
and I did back in great school like or
whatever like oh yeah yeah and it's like
we my friend drew Thanos right in the
middle of it I'm like we never thought
about it looks great he's at the
Infinity gotta yeah I'll tell you though
when you CGI there and that even CJ
would you I think even if you did like
you know a full prosthetic like and you
try to put that in three dimensions
something just was not coming off right
I'm like this guy looked like so it but
it didn't I got used to it as it went on
so I was okay but something was for me
it's when his helmets on i buy it more
the second the helmet comes off and he
just looks like a chewed purple eraser I
think yes I think I mean in terms of the
actual CGI with him I think it's some of
the best I've ever seen
I mean with him moves around the CGI is
bad it's like how do you just his design
that's what yeah there's something some
designs and the earlier designs when
they kept him in the shadows and some of
those things when you keep a character
in the shadows they automatically feel
cooler somebody's running around in
sunlight with his helmet off I'm just
like I'm not blaming the CGI people I
actually picked the CGI and the movie
was really solid I think yeah it's not
that it's that the character design
itself just lends itself to a certain
like yes yeah I thought about it till
now but you know I understand that I
mean didn't really bother me too much I
just thought Josh Brolin's performance
came through that oh absolutely
everything and he was so good he was
great
I didn't there was a I don't think it
was a bad
five percent agreed not crazy is it that
josh brolin played Thanos and cable in
the same summer I know that was amazing
summer bro and I think the other one
that shocked me was a bit was like I did
I didn't like to see Loki go yeah I mean
I guess that's how the whole human count
is perpetuated he might be back I could
see him possibly coming back but even if
he doesn't come back in the main
continuity or in like the present-day
stories they have that Disney Plus show
with him so he's yeah Tom pilson's gonna
be playing a character for years he's
he's the big question mark where I'm
like I know if they're bringing him back
in this movie amber sir if they're just
gonna do like people's stuff with him
yeah I got it I got a friend and she's
totally into Hiddleston and Loki and
she's like you should have warned me
he's the first death I think I don't
know Heimdall dies before ya are the
first step that we really see but yeah
man I mean there's a lot of loss in this
movie and it's first time I've been
really well I liked Thor Ragnarok how
did you a lot but Thor as a character
never really girl see this is the first
time I'm like I am really into this
badass gritty vengeful Thor yeah this
survivor Authority I'm like I like this
though that's why the line I put in
there about what is he gonna do improv
them to death because he's not he's been
sitting Joe key character in Thor
Ragnarok but then he is so cool in
infinity war when he comes up with that
clip I showed with him coming up with
all the electricity in just Jamie I'm
the axe hammer juggled all these
disparate plot threads really really
well I'm like how do you do a movie with
this many characters and I felt like
most of them got their fair share of
screen test I thought that about the
first Avengers movie I was like alright
they're gonna do this it's great the
movies gonna suck but this is a good
starting point we're gonna get better
from here but the movie was really good
yeah that was a good move and they've
improved from that I mean people have a
lot of issues with age of Ultron I know
but in terms of this one right this is
better infinity Wars better than the
first Avengers that's the thing about
Marvel that fascinates me is we always
my brother and I always get accused of
being Marvel chills but you know there's
so many bad movies
mm-hmm that even when I see a bad Marvel
movie
it's not even I'm like it's not a bad
movie it's just a well you thought that
way about you know Captain Marvel I
thought yeah captain Marvel's probably
like it's in my bottom five yeah out of
all of them are coming so it's really
there and like it's not bad
yeah Thor - Thor - and Iron Man - and if
you watch our reviews of them at no
point do I think we say it's like it's a
terrible movie um there's something to
like the Disney Marvel way of where it's
just like you always get something
that's watchable sure not good grade or
but it's like even there were stuff I'm
like well that's still watch my I
preferred over to half the stuff I see
you know of course in a year or so but
yeah so I mean kudos to them for that
and yeah you know anything else about
infinity war I mean I pretty pretty much
things that we said everything that we
need to say about that one yeah just
really great stuff I'm really excited to
see endgame and how they wrapped the
story up and who's gonna come back who's
gonna be staying dead and where they're
gonna go from here because know after
endgame is gonna be like a whole new
thing I'm focusing on new characters
obviously we already have spider-man far
from home coming out in a couple months
so we'll see what happens when I was
waiting on those spiders yeah watch it
be like it's great but I'm like now my
old friend into the channel Brian Porter
I would stop by his house to watch Game
of Thrones yesterday and I think he got
the the the soundtrack to in the spider
were a spider of her son vinyl and he
was playing and I was like and they had
the desire and the run of record I was
like that's the coolest ring I got it I
gotta just my phone like OD and iTunes
yeah but it's it's amazing yeah yeah
that was the first thing I'm like I need
this soundtrack yeah absolutely I can't
wait to see more of spider-verse but I
think we're gonna move into predictions
for endgame here so this is going up on
a Tuesday and Avengers and game is
officially coming out on Thursday
evening what are some of your
predictions where my prediction is at
the end of it Thanos is killed Captain
America rips off his helmet and reveals
Keyser sze waiting for it I think Kevin
Spacey's probably if I'm the gas center
of the and uh good morning
gomorrah's bet I I think do you think
anyone's coming back I don't know what
her deal is so I don't know if the
actress wants out it was if Zoey wants
out then I mean then she's not coming
back but I think she does I mean she
came out my big support of James Gunn
yeah so she's if she's still game to be
in it I feel like she's coming back
along with pretty much anybody that got
dusted sure and then my prediction is
definitely Iron Man's gone or at lead I
or what gives up the helmet like I'm
done because Robert Downey jr. has made
it very clear I think he's done yeah
guys yeah and he's been he's been doing
this for well over a decade face of it
for alone and he's been great so no I
mean it'll be sad the same go but I'm
like no that's a good run um yeah he's
great I think him Captain America are
the two that I think are going they'll
be the sacrifice basically to bring
everyone else yeah
maybe a couple of the secondary
characters left standing
oh go but that's that's agreement that's
pretty much what I'm figuring for who
lives and dies so my hopeful prediction
is that brie Larson will be able to turn
in a decent performance this time with
someone else - I like this will be think
it's her fault I think this is yeah this
is gonna be the big this is gonna be the
big this will be the answers we've been
looking for like okay who was it was at
these two directors who came from an
independent film background and we're
clearly out of their depth like they
should not have been picked for that
movie or is it brie Larson herself or is
it a little accounting I think it was
the story that they were trying to tell
with her you know having the memory loss
and stuff and yeah maybe they just
couldn't figure out a way to play it
where is interesting enough and still
having kind of that
you know amiga thing going on yeah but
she was I thought she was super dull in
that movie no she was absolutely I'm
she's not that she's a good actress
that's why I was good I used I'm like
what I've seen you act yeah what is
going on is this the director is this
the script is the line I always point
out is when she's trapped with like the
gauntlets or whatever around her hands
and she's like escaping and run away
barefoot or whatever and like she's
closed in by the other scrolls or
whatever's going on there and she looked
turns it to them it goes like any of you
guys know how to get these off and like
has no emotion whatsoever in that line
no my biggest problem is the whole the
whole point of that movie was about gas
lighting and there's all these guys
telling her don't have emotion no
emotion I'm like okay well there's gonna
be payoff like there's gotta be parents
like so finally it's like I'm gonna have
a motion and it's literally the exact
same performance she's at the whole film
I'm like well if that's your whole point
of this movie then you need to have her
have an emotion and she ever did even
when she's there idea of giving her
emotion is to just give her fireballs
out of her hands I'm like well that's
not emotion that's just a supervisor
so I'm hopeful like I'm hopeful but I'll
be honest that the trailer did not or
that um at the end of the trailer where
tops up like I like rolled my eyes
instantly where it's like I'm gonna do
that thing yeah that's weak yeah and I'm
just like we'll see oh you mean the
hammer yeah that's really what they
hammered it and then doors like this I
like this one and I'm like oh please God
just don't cuz I was like is that all
they're gonna let her do is just wink ah
I think that you know a lot of people
were concerned that she was gonna be
like the focal point of this movie for
some reason she was kind of kind of
coming to save the day I think that
she's gonna be holding down the fort
somewhere and like doing a lot of heavy
lifting while our main hero's that we've
been following are changing the timeline
or whatever they're gonna be doing so I
think they're gonna be cross cutting
back and forth with her we're gonna get
some character building with her but
she's not gonna be a focus I think
that's the focus is gonna be on the
group of characters that we've been
following I mean that this it were
already screwed with character building
with her because they didn't do it in
the movies so at this point I'm just
hoping for a good performance I mean I'm
doing like the Hulk movie
right they didn't think Bruce Banner was
done yeah I actually kind of liked
incredible Hawking like online I enjoyed
that movie still but gangly one
no not Hulk okay Incredible Hulk but
then forget okay so it was Hulk The
Incredible Hulk yeah that which is in
the MCU universe never yeah but but now
everyone loves the Hulk when he shows up
as a secondary character so maybe
they'll be the same thing I'm hoping
they do that with her and I'm hoping
it's a good performance and I'm hoping
that it like makes up for the fact that
they didn't know how to tell a story
previously but that's the promise the
Russo brothers now are inheriting that
mess so it's like and were they away but
here's the thing I were they aware of
this or they just being handed this
character and it's like don't worry we
already told this story here's what that
story was just just run with this I'm
like so I'm hoping that they're able to
like like do something with it like but
I mean well this was the big problem
with Black Panther is when you looked at
infinity war like I've seen some people
coming like there was enough
what kinda never I didn't know nobody
move yeah they were shooting those
simultaneous yeah there's no way that
the plan was I'm just finishing up well
the OVA was in production so so yes I'm
hopeful that like this still works out
and this is the one problem with an
extended universe like this and when
you've got these overlapping projects
it's like man if something goes wrong or
there's like a hang-up somewhere where
the other ones is like they can create a
ripple effects I'm hoping it doesn't
happen I'm hoping she's good right I
mean and like I said I don't think
Captain Marvel is a bad movie I just and
I don't think a lot of people disagree
with us we might even be in the minority
because I know a lot of people really
really like that movie so that's just
our opinions on that I thought it was
like screen writing 101 fails which is
really rare for marbles I don't know
what was up with that yeah it was
interesting in some ways I kind of
connect I love the stuff with her
getting up there the montage of her
getting up everything I was saying like
I love that montage I wish she was in a
better movie because I looked at all
those little girls going well you're
gonna grow up to be this Bor
No yeah I just want to see some more
charisma that's all I know he's
obviously great actress I think she can
do this I'm very excited to see where
they go with her yeah I'm hoping so
we'll see what happens with her
character but in terms of any other
predictions that I have for endgame I
also think cap and Iron Man are dead I
don't think they're gonna live - you
know like retirement or whatever I think
they're both gone
I think a strong possibility is that
we're gonna see Winter Soldier take up
the Captain America mantle like as
happened in the comics from the Ed
Brubaker run mm-hmm where Winter Soldier
took over for Captain America we're
gonna see maybe new custody or just like
him picking up the shield it's gonna be
obvious and then they're gonna reveal
that the actual title of the Winter
Soldier and Falcon series that's gonna
be on Disney Plus is gonna be Captain
America in the Falcon and it's gonna be
the new Captain America with the I could
see it that's what I think that's a big
thing like that would be smart
yeah well I know if Disney's gonna do
that but right I'm just this is very
he'll miss sometimes when you just like
right we'll see but I do think that's
that's a not a strong possibility but at
least a moderate case I think he's
taking notes right now Oh in terms of
anything else
I don't think Loki's coming back but I
think there's a 30% chance that we'll
get like a little tease or something
I think Thor might die honestly there's
a chance that Thor might die I don't
think it's I think everyone's kind of
expecting cap I think I think the second
I saw Ragnarok did pretty good they're
they're gonna want to do another one I
do think if he was gonna die the studio
notes I think I've come in and said
don't I think that they're gonna throw a
curve ball at us that we're not
expecting because a lot of people are
expecting and anticipating cap and or
care or someone else gonna die so who's
it gonna be
these pepper gonna die I don't know so
something Crazy's gonna I know something
else that we're not expressing is going
to happen peppers too small of a
character it's got to be like or maybe
she dies and then Iron Man's
I got no reason let's just finish this
and then you guys please no it's so
freaking cliche he finds out that she
didn't she got dusted I don't think she
actually got dusted but I think we're
gonna see Valkyrie in this movie Tessa
Thompson's character from Ragnarok which
I'm dead
I've loved fel create like the from
Ragnar I gonna say it's like one of my
favorite actresses right yeah she was
awesome
I'm looking forward to seeing that I'm
even looking forward to that men in
black movie honestly cuz she looks
pretty funny in that her and I'm looking
forward to oh yeah they're again
anything that comes out and like we're
talking about ghostbusters it's like I
hope it's good but you get that sick
sense it's this thing right I mean men
and blacks a franchise I would love to
be good because I love to the original I
actually thought the third was pretty
good the second one's garbage hmm third
one is decent yeah well anyway yeah the
second one is terrible who else they
would kill off them be big enough thank
you but see that's a that's a character
you can afford to park with like that
Hulk no Hulk is that secondary carrier
to pop up I could see them killing Thor
maybe to be brought back later
I maybe he's the one okay I'll give you
this if you kill Thor you can kill Thor
but I'm like he ain't really dead he'll
come back I feel I feel like they're
they're jonesing for a fourth like Thor
movie yeah like yeah you're right after
how successful Ragnarok was but we'll
see what happens in terms of how they
fix this I think it's gonna be some kind
of time-travel thing I think a lot of
people have been thinking that but also
it could be something else I don't know
maybe they're gonna take the fight to
fan house and some other way we saw in
the trailers they have those suits those
like matching suits that are like white
and black and stuff and there's space
battles in the comics so I'm hopeful
right no that's not why I'm gonna be in
there for sure I
do you think it's gonna be a time-travel
thing or what have you got a time stone
what are you right so they're gonna have
to go steal the time stone and then use
it to power try to remember what cheese
I'm gonna I'm gonna have to find a copy
all right get down I feel the presence
of an actual time stone hmm yeah is it
the most
so we'll see what happiness but I don't
know there could be another way they go
about it we'll see what happens though
everyone keeps talking about because I
think the quantum realm is the gauntlets
just this big giant magical MacGuffin
device so if that's always the thing
when I was like watching it like even if
I had no knowledge of it the second you
just talk about how powerful the
gauntlet is I'm like then really you
just need to get that from him and like
just how they make it well yeah you know
we'll see what happens but I do think
the quantum realm was gonna be involved
in some capacity because they set that
up and I am in the wasp yeah and it's
gonna be involved in some case either
ant-man by himself or everyone's gonna
have to go in there to go back in time
something's gonna happen with that I'm
really looking forward to it I have not
been this excited about a movie in a
while I mean I get excited about a lot
of the big movies and stuff that I'm
interested in but this one this is like
a combination of the past 11 years
I am excited for it I think I'm more
excited to it's been a long time like
probably a little bit of that would like
force awakens or it's like I was like
that probably sounds like return of a
king where I felt like wow I'm watching
an event right this feels like an event
and it's three hours long just like
Return of the King your pitches and your
craps right before you go it's but no I
I'm excited to feel like I'm a part of
like this giant thing that's gonna have
some more moreso than like just seeing
the movie that something's like I'm
excited to see the movie but I feel like
to a certain degree I'm like okay like
at least I is so it's just like but in
the throws curve ball game they'll throw
a curve ball but I'm not I'm not as into
it like from that like like
what's gonna happen it's more like yeah
it's gonna be super cool to see all
these other people super excited about
it like really into it and like there is
like an infectious in this like when
nerds like get together yeah for sure
fan they're not excited about something
I mean it's rare and rare nowadays but
this is I think as an exception yeah
everyone's pretty hyped about a game so
it's like as is that was a huge fan of
Captain Marvel but like there are a lot
of people who ever like loved in the
movie and I'm like great like it's fun
seeing a moment like I'd rather see a
movie where at least audiences are split
but you know that some people enjoyed it
versus when you see movie that's so bad
and just people walk out like you feel
like like Jesus I'm just depressed yeah
well I'm very excited for it you're very
excited for it I think in general people
are looking forward to this one so I
hope you guys enjoy that movie when you
see it on Thursday in terms of I guess I
should explain a little bit why I wanna
do is X not your thing so a lot of
people enjoy the the over-the-top crazy
portrayal of Zach's lair it's not at all
accurate it's just a weird a very
strange all right so again the character
a lot of people seem to like it sort of
like doing it it brings joy to people
for the most part I think so yes cuz
this stupid voice is why I like doing it
cuz it makes me laugh and it makes a
line you laugh so you know the I got the
idea a while back and just to do a
lighter one the comedic one they were
talking about and also Snyder came out
with these comments did you hear about
those I quoted it in the video he had a
screening of Ben and he's Superman and
somebody asked him like in an interview
what he thinks about people being upset
that Batman kills and I know you're not
a big proponent you know I'm not the one
to talk to you about this about it my
Batman was Michael Keaton that guy was a
serial yes absolutely
but his response to it was just this
over-the-top profane thing visually I
think he always always looked so good
for the most part they do action scenes
III won't I will I have a small quibble
with you're like well desaturate the
whole thing cuz he does he does
strangely enough they own a lot of
have real pops of color sometimes I mean
300 everything's very purple and a
program kind of he does suck but like
Man of Steel there's no color in that
movie there's a couple like spots but
mostly it's very disaccharide in doesn't
there was more color I thought there was
no you're writing about credit for all
right watch me I love Watchmen as a
visual yeah absolutely but in terms of
his I have to hesitate to say
comprehension his take or his angle on
the characters or his interpretation of
the characters IV mately disagree with
it's obvious and especially from that
quote that he just doesn't behold to the
same things the core values that a lot
of people I'll hold these characters hey
you know to themselves as I'm all for
different points of view when it comes
by and like my problem my problem is
okay my promise Snyder is it's people
like Dan went to a darker take on
Superman cool I want to see a dark take
on Superman I also want it to be good
right that's like the prophets not that
it's a darker take or even his his weird
theories I'm like you know that these
people are like God man yeah living like
there's a part of me them like that
could be really interesting he for some
reason does not have the tools to
execute that vision way that makes a
good movie that's where I the great
storyteller that when you might be right
and you know just putting piecing
together a story even though I do think
that the the extended cut or the
whatever they call it the cut from PBS
that is significantly better ya know
they should have released that like like
these little pilot oh there are attempts
to always with WB's like fix it always
make him yes and I've never hated his
axe neither movie except maybe sucker
punch oh really didn't like but I've
never like really hated his x9r movie
like they're just like REO is alright
but it's not like no it's Superman movie
I want to max like fits me it's like
fascinating ideas that he just he
doesn't know how to execute alright what
it is but it's just like I'm like cuz
when I hear him talk and like we can
talk about crazy sometimes
he's very passionate be interested to
see a really good take on that idea I
think it's just you're not the guy to do
it you can write somebody run with this
idea of lyft storyboards make the
storyboards cookus problem I feel like
he's got like good ideas I'm like no
that's interesting I'd be very
fascinated to see that but then he does
it I'm like yeah it's just right
execution is seems to be the problem
with him but yeah I mean it's just it's
nothing personal it's not like I you
know like have a strong dislike for the
guy it's great that he gets that you got
the hang on the keys that make these
movies that's that's great honestly I
feel like their impression doesn't many
more favors because I find him strangely
kind of likable with that silly boy I
like my version of him is like this
weirdly optimistic yeah I kind of liked
it like I like that like yeah it's it's
a different take on I'm for sure then
I've seen interviews and stuff but
anyway that's kind of why I wanted to
put it out there is like it's kind of
timely with those comments that he made
and I made the rounds online and stuff
and you know if any words coming out I
thought yeah let's just see what we
could turn with this so yeah it was good
he had personal tragedies so he looks
like he's moving away from those and
that's why we stopped doing that and I
was like yeah and DC now is like going a
different route I'm also a lot of people
are for a lot of people really love that
she's a movie a lot of people loved
Aquaman like she's MCAS like that's the
thing it's not they're not being Marvel
right which is what I like I never
wanted that and they're like well
because if they tell a joke it's Marv
I'm like no like should there's not what
Shazam I'm like there is nothing really
Marvel to me about this Marvel would
just not make this movie to me it just
doesn't feel like a Marvel movie um even
Wonder Woman to me like does that feel
like there is something and it's it's
the advantage of having characters that
are also for the most part intrinsically
different for Marvel yeah like these
godlike characters which is interesting
and like that's why I liked Wonder Woman
and then Shazam is the closest you could
argue maven to Marvel but it didn't feel
like Marvel at all to me and it got
really great okay that's some of the
stuff I was like I loved it for that I
know a lot of people I know people love
them
I mean my gripes are small with it but
like I I was really hoping it would be
more of something I would enjoy better
but it's still and still enjoyable I'm
glad people like it I hope DC keeps
being successful so yeah I hope they
keep going down this this route cousin I
know I said I grew up a bigger DC fan I
grew up with DC mu we didn't have Marvel
movies when I was a kid yeah we didn't
actually 90 captain um yeah but yeah
like we ignite here I grew up with DC I
like I have a nostalgic attachment yeah
to DC movies so watching them screw up
actually really upsets no inside for a
place where like I hate DC I don't think
Oh dad's like no I want you to get it
right right and that's why I'm more not
protective but I'm more invested in them
doing Superman right than Batman right
because we've seen Batman done
fantastically it does oh yeah a bunch of
times and not even just on the movies
but on like the small screen with TV
shows and cartoons
oh yeah stuff so it's like Batman's been
done fantastic and it's an easy but
easier care it is an easier character
Superman it's very tough to handle him
because he's such a he's such a product
of his time in the Golden Age of comic
books yeah and it's hard to adapt him to
different time period that's where
daughters actively daughter didn't got
it right because they're just like okay
a sense of humor yes and be campy but
we're also gonna tell literally a
mythological story that's how Puzo saw
it he's like alright we're gonna tell a
great God myth yes and it's and it's
done great and I still love watching
those movies to this day I think they've
aged great even though it takes place in
the 70s it feels like it maybe could
have even taken place in the 40s or 50s
like it's it's just it's like New York
its metropolis is like a strange it's
mostly China it's very yet it's very 70s
some of the effects are dated but there
is a timelessness to it because of that
absolutely and I just want to see you
can have him be more realistic you can
have him be more little bit more
pessimistic or a little bit darker but
the core of the character needs to be
there and I don't think manage steel had
that I don't think Batman V Superman had
that and I want to see a great Superman
movie again and I may be doing that on
fan scription one day
keeping a half nothing but keeping out
for that one um Rob your your little
brother's gonna be taking over my little
brother
people say that looks like you were the
younger one no no as the older brother
myself little tyke take over see how he
does yeah because I don't think he
doesn't bring success anywhere he goes
no we're taking a gambling gonna be a
huge game no he wants to do Mary Poppins
returns yes interesting which I didn't
realize I just said it now I'm like what
a generic title that is it Mary Poppins
returns like how many returns a Batman
Returns
I just think Superman Returns anyway so
he wants to do that he's talking about
me he's like oh maybe I'll do Mary
Poppins as an editorial like Mary
Poppins returns as an editorial and then
do ya miss Dallas really gonna talk I
don't want to confirm that or anything
we won't confirm him but he's he's he's
mulling it over right now but Van
scription will be next month featuring
Doug writing for his version of Mary
Poppins returns he's a big fan of the
original film so I am too I love that
movie yeah I apparently Malcolm had not
seen it so out here on the channel as
well a lot of stuff going he loved it
too so yeah yeah yeah after that you'll
have another one and then they'll be
back yeah remember I will be back in a
couple months with a brand new episode
of fan scription I will be back in June
with probably a spider-man related one
so I see towards the end of that month
what I'm gonna be tackling but I have
some some interesting ideas how to take
that I'm looking forward to you guys
seeing that one anything else you want
to say right anything else but if any
more endgame or anything I'm looking
forward to it yeah it's been a long day
for us folks well yeah if you're
wondering why we're stumbling half the
time it's like we've been filming for
hours and hours
the next NC is gonna be a law
boy yes keeping out for that also got a
lot of new stuff coming up I know a lot
of people been asking us about whatever
we're still doing fan scription which is
new and this podcast is still new but
there's always what's downstream on us
all right yeah but there's a lot of new
stuff coming out with Heather Roose and
Ayana Wade and and a whole crew or we
gonna Lance just a plan please be
patient we are working on it Tim
Burton's Batman I'm working on homework
I'm working on it and goes back on the
phone
so next month for the podcast we'll
probably have Doug here Rob obviously
you can join us as well Mabel have a
three-person podcast for that one we'll
see we'll be back next month with Mary
Poppins returns enjoy endgame everybody
I hope you like the movie hope it's good
I hope it's good as well well I'm sure
you'll be doing a sibling rivalry oh
yeah I'll be reviewing on my personal
channel too everyone's gonna be talking
about this movie so I hope you like it
enjoy this time because it may never be
here again enjoy all right
live in the moment in the moment this
might be the peak of the Marvel stuff
we'll see we'll see what happens well
it's certainly DC's on the rise now
right personal opinion so it's like all
right finally some competition yeah so
we'll see what happens going forward so
thank you guys for watching or listening
and we'll catch you back here on the
podcast or on a brand new episode of a
fan scription next month see you later
[Music]
you